all right humans and other assorted life
forms it is september 13th
2021 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message and tomorrow
is the big day
the fate of the state of california and
perhaps the country will be decided yes
i have already voted for my man larry
elder we'll talk about that in just a
minute yes
that old fella in the white house joe
biden is campaigning for gavin newsom
here in california today which perhaps
do they think this may not go exactly as
they want
and uh yes a lot of people are concerned
about the legitimacy of the vote you
don't have to show ids i did a video on
that which i'll reference a bit more in
just a little while
a lot of people are just kind of worried
and now there's all sorts of videos
coming out it's actually being picked up
believe it or not by at least local
media here in california about some
voter irregularities people getting a
bunch of uh ballots in one case a woman
confirming that she got five ballots i
talked last week about my buddy colin
moriarty who's been on the show a few
times who left california two years ago
got a ballot to vote while he lives in
virginia now all sorts of crazy stuff so
we're going to show you a little bit
of a video from a local news affiliate
on what's going on with voting machines
in this area here in los angeles
the second story we're going to cover
today is just like general covid
craziness there's just so much craziness
with vaccine mandates and
people saying the reverse of what they
said when trump was in the
administration and all of the rest of it
uh and uh now this fouchy guy remember
fauci uh he's saying that uh yeah he'd
be for making sure that if you get on a
plane you are vaccinated so the creep of
this thing just continues and then
finally i want to do a story on bill
maher you guys know bill maher he is
sort of the last remaining liberal i
suppose
and he talked on his show this week
about why he's always hitting the left
and i was watching the clip and i was
just like man i've just sort of had it
with these last liberals like these last
liberals who are still pretending that
they can't figure out what time it is as
the world burns and i know that a bunch
of bill maher producers watch the show
so i'll be talking directly to you guys
and as always i'm willing to talk about
this directly to bill either on this
show or on his show but mostly i want to
focus on the election today and real
quick before we get to any of that uh
this past weekend we're going to show
you some some stills
as i'm talking but this past weekend i
was at the dan crenshaw youth summit of
course dan crenshaw congressman from
texas and
he's just a fantastic guy obviously i've
had him on the show true fighter for
america and american values and you can
see it just about 2 000 kids at this
event it was just really spectacular it
was mostly high school and college kids
so it was a young audience and it was
just great first off to just be back
around big crowds and really nobody was
wearing masks and i'm sure nobody's
gonna die and megan kelly spoke and ben
shapiro spoke and michael knowles spoke
and a bunch of people in my circles and
it was nice to see people tony robbins
connected with tony robbins who is just
a great guy and a huge he's a large
large man but it was just great to be
out and about and see that young people
are ready to fight like you know i've
talked a little bit about how the
generational thing here is a little
screwy the baby boomers don't seem to be
letting go like joe biden and nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer these people
should have nothing to do with
controlling our lives at this point in
the idea that they're writing policy
that will
relate to a young person's life in in
such a time of change is just so crazy
so it was just great to see young people
that are like excited about america that
realize everything screwy that want to
fix things
etc etc guys before i get to any of that
i just mentioned in a recent interview
how when i took a look back on my first
prager video my first prageru video i
was pretty stressed at the time and i
can see some like pretty terrible bags
under my eyes i wasn't sleeping a lot i
was stressed i was getting a lot of hate
you know i left the left people were
pissed i had these bags and and some
puffiness under my eyes that are a
problem for millions of american men and
women until now introducing the new
genus cell serum with plant stem cell
technology from showmany susan from new
jersey road i've been using jen yourself
for a couple months the puffiness around
my eyes is gone even the crow's feet and
the small lines have disappeared and
haven't come back i love your product i
use it under my eyes around my
cheekbones and on my eyelids not only
susan folks and with their immediate
effects you'll see results in the first
12 hours or your money back they
guarantee it order now and get fifty
percent off all gen yourself packages
during the final days uh of their end of
summer clearance sale at love
genusell.com dave again that's love
c g-e-n-u-c-e l dot com slash dave love
geniuselle.com
dave and now back to me okay so let's
talk about the election look i've i've
given this thing everything i got i know
biden's here today and obama's putting
out ads for newsome and he had kamala
harris here and elizabeth warren here
and bernie's tweeting about it and aoc
is tweeting about it but larry elder's
got me
he's got scott baio he's got
rose mcgowan
he's got john voigt he put out a video
yesterday and i like our chances okay
but yes it does feel like that the
machine in california this is just what
people feel and and you may go okay well
facts don't care about your feelings but
there's a problem if half the people in
the country or in any given state don't
feel that the machinery
is going to allow for a legitimate
election and that's what a lot of people
feel everyone that i've taught i kid you
not i think every single person
that has approached me either this past
weekend at the crenshaw event or when
i'm out and about here in cali everyone
in the last couple weeks that approaches
me about the election they say the same
thing do you think larry has a chance my
answer is always yes right like there is
a chance like there is there is energy
there is a push back like it's here he's
the right guy that's why the media hates
him so much that's why they're bringing
in the the big guns to stop him but then
the second question is will they fix it
or what will they do or how corrupt is
california it's always the same some
version of the same question and i don't
know what the answer to that is uh if
you haven't seen it yet we posted a
video over the weekend where i took my
entire team out to vote so a whole bunch
of us went out to vote we voted at our
local polling station here i put my
paper ballot in four times so it's an
electronic screen but you have a paper
ballot that you have to put in i put it
in four times it rejected it four times
then kicked me out of the system so the
system then reset my paper came out and
it was completely misprinted you can see
the video for yourself it's on youtube
right now you can see that the printer
sort of went over itself so the qr code
got all screwed up the system reset now
they did let me vote again but i think
an awful lot of people that might have
happened to them and they wouldn't even
realize that their vote did not count
now one of the guys at the polling
station said he knew me i couldn't tell
if that meant he liked me or not but
like
okay so i'm telling you something and we
show photographic evidence in the video
so i'm not making this up um you have to
press in california at least at the
polling station i went to to get to
larry elder's name
on the ballot you have to press more
it's an electronic screen like an iphone
screen you have to press more eight
times one two
three four five six seven eight to find
larry elder's name i'm just putting that
out there i'm not saying that's voter
fraud i'm just saying like if you were
uh you know if you wanted people to not
really figure out exactly what to do and
people some people are saying it's
random i don't know
so all that happened and then i want to
bring up one other thing and then we're
going to show you some some video from a
local uh la affiliate here that's that's
tracking some of this stuff um
one of the poll guys
at the place that we went to told one of
my employees that the machines the
electronic machines that you're putting
the paper into that they actually don't
count votes
the machines don't count votes well guys
what could they possibly do what he told
us was that the machines track that you
voted so that you can't vote somewhere
else and that that seems pretty good
even though guys guess what you don't
have to show an id i did not have to
show an id it could be anybody but
that's all the machines do that's what
the pollster at
the place that we voted told us that all
it's doing is confirming that you voted
there so that you can't then go to
another place although you could just
pretend you were someone else since you
don't have to show id
but that's the idea that they then count
them after now we know since you don't
have to show an id and i'm pretty sure
there are no cameras like what are all
the
firewalls what are all the systems that
are in place to make sure that you don't
have a bunch of activists that are
counting votes and aren't just going to
throw things away i have no idea i have
no idea so that's why i'm just saying i
personally don't have tremendous
confidence and i think it's wise to ask
some of these questions and meanwhile
now there is some video coming out of a
couple local affiliates that other
people in california are having some
problems voting with lots of ballots
showing up people going to places where
it says they voted already and a whole
bunch more let's take a look at some
video
we spoke with several concerned voters
here in the west san fernando valley who
believe something wonky had been going
on at places like el camino real charter
high school in woodland hills this place
opened up as an early polling location
open
10 a.m to 7 p.m daily but several people
tell us they showed up to vote this
morning in the special california
governor recall election and were told
that computers showed they had already
cast their ballots so what
staffers they say were apologetic and
helpful but those voters we talked to
are extremely concerned suspicious and
wanting answers
okay so none of this is necessarily
evidence of anything but you know a lot
of people were concerned about the
presidential election when you tell
people that you don't have to show ids
when you don't have cameras confirming
that we're going to count this stuff
honestly when the machines themselves
don't count and you leave it to humans
as i was just told the place i voted
like what level of faith should we have
in the system and you know the other
problem is once
you break that faith like that
incredible bond in a in a democracy
where people vote that bond that oh one
person one vote your vote will count
once you break that once that once that
meme is in the system like oh maybe it
isn't right well then everything else
will start collapsing
on top of that and we do seem to be in
this time of things collapsing right
we're all feeling that and it's partly
like a system only works if enough of us
have faith in that system um so when
they tell you you don't have to show ids
and the rest of it it's like are they
trying to actually just break the faith
in the system i think that's possible
if you want i although i'd never
recommend anyone spend any time on
twitter i have tweeted out some other uh
stuff related to
questions about the election and i've
asked people to tag me in things so that
i can just amplify if you were watching
this right now and you got two ballots
or you got ballots out of state or that
i mentioned the people that i met the
other night who moved to vegas and they
both got ballots in vegas even they
don't live in california anymore if you
have any evidence of any of this stuff
please email it to us well you can email
it to us at support reubenreport.com and
we'll we'll send it to the right people
or put it out on twitter so i can
amplify it immediately and again i am
not a journalist i am one guy
trying to tell you what i think about
the world and uh and i have a voice and
a platform at least for now to do that
so that's that's what i'm trying to do
and if you have not voted
please go vote if you live in california
like despite all of this
like just go vote
and vote in person you know they're
letting people print ballots at home
it's all so freaking ridiculous
but guys we have to have hope we have to
see that star in the distance and
there's always a chance and it seems to
me
them sending biden here and the fact
that obama put out a video and
everything else it's kind of like they
have to be at least a little bit nervous
and just the awful way if for no other
reason
if you have if you can't think of one
reason to vote if you like the
homelessness if you like the drug
use on the streets if you like the high
taxes and the high housing prices if you
like all that stuff um maybe just do it
because of the way they've treated larry
elder that the media has treated him
horribly consistently saying that he's
far right and that he's going to kill
kids and a monkey costume woman a
gorilla costume woman's throwing eggs at
him and and they're calling him a white
supremacist and the horrible way that
they treat him if
you can't think of any other reason
to say yes on this recall and vote for
larry elder how about just to stick it
to the media that that would be good
enough all right let's talk about this
covid situation because as i said i was
just in texas and in texas you know what
a couple people were wearing masks and
god bless them it's your choice to put
anything on your face if you'd like to
and it's your choice to be injected with
anything if you'd like to i'm cool with
that that's just fine you just can't
tell me what to do with my body which
used to be a thing that the lefties
would say uh but there's all sorts of
crazy things happening uh now
related to coven first i want to show
you um well on a more somber note for
just a moment obviously this past
weekend saturday was the 20th
anniversary of 9 11. as many of you know
i wrote about it in my book and i've
talked about a few times here i was in
new york city
during 9 11. i did a video that we
posted on locals just about what it was
like to be in new york city at the time
and uh and obviously it's a solemn time
and you know it's hard to imagine that
20 years later sort of here's where
america is at after that horrific thing
the reason i'm mentioning 911 related to
covet is that they're at one of the
memorials they had obama there and they
had biden and and clinton bill clinton
looks like death walking right now by
the way um but anyway here's joe biden i
want you to just see what he does here
if you don't think that masks and all of
this nonsense is nonsense take a look at
this video watch what he does related to
he has the mask takes off well watch it
the murderers look they're murderers
[Applause]
whoa you're a mod for what you did to
afghanistan
terrible terrible
don't snap him
terrible
[Music]
okay so there's a couple things that
happen there first off the reason that
that video went viral was not because of
what happened with the mask it was
because of the people booing him and the
guy that yelled
don't don't sniff him meaning biden
walked with the mask he has the mask on
then when he gets close to the people to
shake their hands what does he do he
takes the mask down he touches the
person right he shakes a hand and then
what's the thing then he he kisses his
own hand can we just come on
[Applause]
[Music]
terrible
regardless of your feelings on masks in
general and vaccines and everything else
what would be the one thing that maybe
you wouldn't want to do
once you shake somebody's hand if we're
to believe that this pandemic is as bad
as you want especially if you're a what
79 year old guy with
i don't want to say dementia old persons
syndrome like he's got some problems
even the way you see he walks there like
this guy's not in good shape
he takes the mass now when he gets close
to someone he shakes their hand and he
kisses his hand
if imagine if trump did that
imagine if that was trump impeachment
lead of cnn all the usual nonsense that
you know about uh all right let's show
you video two here are we gonna go right
to fouchy now is that what we're doing
which one oh okay so let's let's do a
little bit more on uh biden so here's
just a little bit of a compilation this
is from rnc research of kamala and biden
saying things about vaccines
before they were the president and vice
president enjoy so let's just say
there's a vaccine that is approved and
even distributed before the election
would you get it
well
i think that's going to be an issue for
all of us if and when the vaccine comes
it's not likely to go through all the
tests that needs to be ended trials that
are needed to be done when we finally do
god willing get a vaccine who's going to
take the shot
who's going to take the shot you're
going to be the first one to say put me
sign me up
they now say it's okay and the question
of whether it's real when it's there
that requires enormous transparency
you got to make all of it available to
other experts across the nation
so they can look and see so there's
consensus this is a safe vaccine if the
president announced tomorrow we have a
vaccine would you take it
only if it was completely transparent
that other experts in the country could
look at it only if we knew all of what
went into it if donald trump can't give
answers an administration can't give
answers to these three questions the
american people should not have
confidence but if donald trump tells us
i should that we should take it i'm not
taking it
you know if it was hard for you to watch
those clowns say those things that if
they said those things now they'd
probably be banned from twitter or you
know just kicked out of polite society
if it's hard for you to watch that we
have to watch it a couple times when
we're setting up the show and my
director connor turned to me in the
middle of that one and said how is this
guy president like that's what we're all
realizing how is this guy president i
actually don't think he's president i
mean i know it says it on his desk or on
the paper that he's always looking at
like i believe he was sworn in as
president united states but he's
obviously not the guy in charge anyway
the point is when trump was the one that
was doing operation warp speed and we're
gonna get everybody vaccinated
everything else uh kamala harris i don't
trust it i don't trust trump joe biden
who would trust this it has to be
transparent do you feel that everything
feels transparent right now like the
level
of lies with these people is absolutely
extraordinary and they know they can do
it because the media runs cover for them
and i would say the bigger problem at
this point and i think my track record
on this has been pretty good is that
it's never going to stop until we stop
it and i don't even know exactly what
that means through elections or just
like some sort of national divorce or
whatever else but meaning
you could watch videos from i think
probably by the end of march of 2020
where i kept saying the old world is not
coming back and it's becoming very very
clear that's not coming back like it's
gone it's gone try to remember your life
if you can
i'll do a
five seconds of silence here try to
remember your life back in january of
2020 do you even remember it
it's kind of hard right it's kind of
hard to remember what it was like before
this but i know it was better than this
nonsense that we're dealing with now and
they're just going to keep coming and if
you don't think so well here's uh fauci
now talking about mandating that
everyone who gets on a plane should have
to wear a mask if we get the
overwhelming proportion of the
population vaccinated we will get to
hurt immunity if we do it in the next
six months it will happen in the next
six months if we do it in the next two
months it'll happen in the next two
months i would support that if you want
to get on a plane and travel with other
people that you should be vaccinating
when you hear us say should you mandate
vaccination for children to be able to
attend school
some people say oh my goodness that
would be terrible to do that but we
already do that and have been doing that
for decades and decades i don't know
what school you went to but the school
that i went to you had to be vaccinated
for measles mumps rubella polio or
otherwise you couldn't go to school
so it is not something new
to mandate vaccines for school children
the solution that we have at our hands
is vaccines
measles mumps and rubella kill people
including young people kovid does not
again i don't want to send anyone to
twitter but go look at my twitter i just
retweeted something by congressman
massey
from kentucky about the ages of people
that are dying and young people are just
simply not dying i know that makes
people upset when you say that but
they're not they're not dying young
people have immunity healthy people have
immunity we never talk about stop being
a fat [ __ ] and eat right and take care
of yourself and try medicine
try eating right you know not drinking
all the time not taking drugs not
abusing yourself and you might be okay
your immunity might be okay uh notice
how they've also changed the language it
was two weeks to flatten the curve now
it's quite literally almost two years
later it's over a year and a half later
and it's we don't talk about flattening
the curve nobody even if you were even
to say flatten the curve like if someone
was to bring that up on cnn they
wouldn't even know what to do with it
but we went from two weeks to flatten
the curve to literally he's saying in
two months if everyone gets vaccinated
we'll have herd immunity or it could be
in six months if everyone gets back and
will hurt immunity they're just pushing
and pushing and pushing and pushing and
by the way explain something else to me
i was just on a plane this weekend
michael were you on a plane with me
michael was on a plane with me michael i
want you to shout out if i'm lying about
what i'm about to say when you get on a
plane they play a video and you know
what's on that video first they show you
how to put on a seat belt because
i mean how can you figure out how to put
on a seat belt without uh you know some
very smiley woman telling you how to do
it uh but then you know what they tell
you how safe air travel is and they're
spraying that [ __ ] plane and they're
everything's being sprayed and there's a
green spray gun and they're spraying it
and they give you other anti-microbial
stuff to put you walk in they hand you
something to you know wipe down your
seat it's a very clean thing
isn't it interesting and correct me if
i'm wrong michael feel free to yell at
me again has anyone uh proven that uh
covet is spreading on planes they're
telling us it's like the safest freaking
thing and they're killing 99.9999999999
of all the germs that are getting on the
planes and they do something with the
air they always tell you that i don't
remember what they say about the air
they're doing something fancy they do
some sort of fancy thing with the air as
well but now oh
lord fauci who's gotten everything wrong
lord fauci who as you remember in that
secret email told his friends that masks
don't work and fauci who in a video said
that actually they might not work
because there's spaces in the masks for
the germs to get out and actually it
turns out that you touch your face much
more much like old joe in that video he
was touching his face and then he took
the mess down then he shook someone's
hand then he kissed his hand it's all
[ __ ] do you get it yet everybody
holy cow somebody
um
so all of that and then uh yeah so if
we'll get to hurt immunity in two months
if you do what we want in two months so
it was a year and a half now we have two
months for you to do what you want or
it'll be six months or it'll be eight
months or it'll be 14 years or we're
just going to kill all of you we'll see
what what's what
ridiculous all right we've got a little
bit more here um
should we do the fact the other fouchy
video we'll do the other factory video
right yeah so this is fouchy yeah let's
do this this is fouchy in 2020. uh
talking about vaccine mandates let's see
if he's changed his thoughts
so i'm a physician i see patients in my
hospital
right literally out the window here
across the hall
at the nih clinical center
during the flu season
the administration of the hospital
mandates
that i have to get a flu vaccine
otherwise i won't be able to see
patients the way i usually do
that has not happened ever to my
knowledge
at a national level or even at a state
level so i could see the individual
institutions
mandating a vaccine i don't see it on a
national level merely because of all the
situations you have upon encroaching
upon a person's freedom to make their
own choice of their own health
whoa
who is that guy somebody lock him up
he's concerned about the encroaching uh
freedoms that it might be if you tell
somebody what they should do related to
their own health that put that guy in a
mental institution by the way when he's
saying that he that where he works they
have to mandate it because he works at
the flu center you know what i mean but
now they're mandating it for all of
these federal employees although we'll
get to the caveats in just a second
and for contractors that work with the
united states government so we've got
something from newsweek here and this is
a little bit of what's happened over the
last couple days president joe biden's
new vaccine mandates for federal
employees don't apply to members of
congress or those who work for congress
or the federal court system please come
back to me for just a moment
do you realize how absurd this is they
pass laws that they don't
use on themselves that they don't feel
should affect their lives and their
staff if they're doing something that is
so good and it is so just and it is so
right for all of us well why wouldn't
you want all of the congress members and
their staffs to be vaccinated aren't
politicians super important like we
really need these people i can't have
some young uh you know intern walking
into congress and infecting aoc we need
that woman
let's continue biden issued two
executive orders on thursday requiring
vaccination against covid for federal
workers and contractors who work for the
federal government he also asked the
department of labor to issue an
emergency order requiring businesses
with more than 100 employees to ensure
their workers are vaccinated or tested
on a weekly basis so
you i know you guys know about some of
this already there's all sorts of
lawsuits starting with some of this i'm
thrilled to say you guys know we partner
up and distribute the show with the
blaze the blaze has already said tyler
carden who's a fantastic ceo has already
said they will not abide by this and
they're looking into legal means jeremy
boring over at the daily wire is doing
the same thing there's plenty of other
companies doing it i also want to
mention that when i was on the plane uh
on saturday that a guy tapped me on the
shoulder sitting behind me said he was a
big fan told me that he was actually a
pilot on united and he is uh in a group
of three thousand
three thousand that's not a small number
three thousand employees of united not
just pilots but across the board
who are being told that if they do not
get vaccinated they will be put on
unpaid leave i think he said starting
october 7th
so let's not pretend that everybody is
happy about this and by the way what
happens when say 3 000 employees of an
airline get put on unpaid leave well
first off in essence you're firing them
you're saying well you don't have to
come to work but we're not paying you so
you're firing these people does that
feel right to you guys this was a
perfectly healthy young man okay he
happened to be a fighter in the he was
in the air force before this okay this
was this was a good decent american
um so what do you think might happen do
you think we might have to start having
more delays do you think i don't know
we're getting rid of people that check
the planes for safety and all sorts of
stuff but we're just not going to pay
them we're not going to lay them off
because we're not bad guys we're just
not going to pay them and they don't
have to come to work that that would be
something
what do i have here the cdc originally
required that 67 percent of the
population be vaccinated to achieve herd
immunity uh now they're saying 80
minimum because of delta where's that
coming from can you give me that that's
directly from the cdc okay so you got
that when i i mean i didn't even know
this until michael just threw this up
for me right here but you see what i
mean about everything moving two weeks
to flatten the curve we need sixty-seven
percent of you to be vaccinated for
hurting me now we need eighty percent uh
because delta's scary and then now
there's they're talking about the mu mu
variant yes that's coming too oh god all
right all right all right let's talk
about the lefties because i've got to
calm down and i love those people so
look there there's a couple decent
liberals left there's there's not really
many of them and most of you know my
story and i generally like decent
liberals not woke progressive maniacs
but the few decent liberals that remain
i come from a family of what i would say
are old school jfk liberals for the most
part these people exist but many of them
i would say at this point have woken up
and have said you know what i don't
agree with everything on the
conservative side of things i think
abortion is one that a lot of them are
really concerned about most of them have
moderate beliefs on
uh on when you can do an abortion say 12
weeks something like that that's what i
lay out in my book and i know
conservatives don't agree with that yet
i still get invited to conservative
events and they don't throw eggs at me
while wearing gorilla masks
so i think most decent liberals at this
point have seen what time it is and are
leaving and the progressives can have
their increasingly
small group of hysterical lunatics that
just have a lot of power because they
scream and they control the institutions
well then there's guys like bill maher
bill maher who i've admired for 30 years
probably but really since i was probably
like 12 or something and i started
watching politically and correct and i
was getting into stand-up comedy and
he's been the champion of of liberalism
right and even right now he fights
against woke-ism he fights for free
speech so he's right on a lot of these
things but he is struggling to figure
out what time it is and he sort of
addressed that on the show so let's play
the video and then i will analyze the
chat
to me when people say to me sometimes
like boy you know you go after the left
a lot these days why i'm like because
you're embarrassing me
that's why i'm going after the left in a
way you never did before because you're
inverting things that i i'm not going to
give up on being liberal this is what
these teachers are talking about that
you're taking children and making them
hyper aware of race in a way they
wouldn't otherwise be i mean i i saw
last night on the football game
alicia keys sang lift every voice and
sing
which now i hear is called the black
national anthem now maybe we should get
rid of our national anthem but i think
we should have one national anthem i
think when you go down a road where
you're having two different national
anthems
colleges sometimes now have many of them
have different graduation ceremonies for
black and white
separate dorms this is what i mean
segregation
you've inverted the idea
we're going back to that
under a different name
bill
you have to understand what's going on
here first off i just want to
say thank you for repeating everything
that i was saying five years ago right
i've been screaming about this stuff for
five years watch my why i left the left
video from prageru from five years ago
okay so that's nice and i know that your
guys watch my show so i'll talk directly
to the producers of the show everything
that bill said there is now conservative
yes we shouldn't have two national
anthems i don't know what he meant by we
should maybe change our national anthem
no we shouldn't um but yes they're
teaching racism in school they're
teaching this hyper-racialized thing in
school it's coming there's no liberals
to stand up for this stuff and then he
brings on people like adam schiff on his
show and it's obvious that he supports a
guy like adam schiff and we see this
with all the liberals a guy like bill uh
like joe rogan for example and these are
i'm really trying not to make these
personal attacks i'm trying to talk
about this in the idea set of what these
guys talk about joe rogan uh in in an
odd sense
did the right thing because he was a
bernie supporter which made no sense
right makes no in my view it makes no
sense to be a bernie supporter you sit
down with people like jordan peters and
all these brilliant people for years and
years and years and at the end when it
came down to it for the presidency you
were supporting uh you were supporting
bernie sanders makes no sense but joe
rogan when he signed the 100 million
dollar deal which i'm told is a lot more
than 100 million dollars with spotify he
lived in california and you know what he
did right before he signed the deal he
left he went to texas but the thing that
he was telling everybody to vote for
that he's voting for bernie sanders was
to raise taxes on everybody especially
people like him so the liberals in the
sense they're all still
confused they're looking at their watch
and a watch should be right twice a day
but they can't seem to ever get it right
they can't seem to ever get it right so
it's like bill maher
take the last step here i get it you're
in hollywood you've you've made your
career on being a liberal that is that
is a lofty goal and a worthwhile thing
trust me i get it more than most people
but at this point unless you're willing
to say i will not support any democrats
it doesn't mean the republicans are
great but everything you believe in is
now a republican principle now if you
really still think that high taxation
makes sense if you really still think
that handouts make sense and if
affirmative action makes sense and some
of that stuff well then we just got to
keep teaching you a little bit but i
don't even think he believes in that
stuff i've seen him talk to to ben
shapiro he doesn't really disagree i i
we could send him a couple of time in
seoul videos i don't think he disagrees
with that but i get it his whole brand
and again this isn't an attack on him
his brand is i've been the liberal like
conservatives and this was also the
dangerous if you keep saying that
everybody else the conservatives they're
always racists and bigots and backwards
and in bill's case they're also
believers right they're believers
they're religious so they must be idiots
which is also a big problem that the
liberals have and they better freaking
get over it um well now like he's
painted himself in a corner so he can't
really do anything so anyway so the
producers that i know watch this which
is why bill repeats everything that i
say all the time because even the stuff
right there about national anthems all
that like yeah doing it months ago it's
like bill's welcome here we'll do it
unedited i'm happy to be on his show i'm
not attacking him i don't even really
want to be on the show anymore i've been
canceled a couple times i'm sort of like
it doesn't even it's not even about me i
don't actually
i sort of retract that it doesn't even
matter um but these last liberals it
doesn't make sense i saw even that sam
harris uh while i was gone off the grid
that he basically tweeted out something
to the effect of he's he's swallowing
his words related to supporting biden
it's like yeah we all knew this was
gonna happen but you guys were so afraid
of being called scary conservatives so
you'd rather vote to destroy everything
that america is
but show me a democrat willing to stand
up against this stuff so you can't
support adam schiff you can't tell
people to vote vote for bernie sanders
you can't sit there as the world burns
and your your entire side is collapsed i
go ah you're making liberals look bad
it's like no liberals made liberals look
bad right like like come on bill come on
bill anyway guys i have an extremely
busy day today and then a banana's busy
day tomorrow i'm on like 87 shows
talking about the election i'm actually
headed right now uh what show am i doing
on fox this afternoon
which one
which which uh am i doing newsroom
what's the afternoon show that i'm doing
somebody help me here i'm doing one of
the afternoon shows on fox they're
taping live on location in los angeles
so i'm leaving here what is it newsroom
oh martha mccallum i'm doing martha
mccallum show you see it's been i've
been busy uh doing martha mccallum's
show so we're heading out we're going
there so i'll be live on fox i think in
about an hour from now maybe an hour and
a half or so uh guys part two of my
interview with rose mcgowan who by the
way did a press conference with larry
elder this weekend i'd even talk about
that
she's got the freaking email where gavin
newsom's wife says what can harvey
weinstein's lawyer do for you
what do you think a lawyer can do for
for heart for rose mcgowan a rape victim
and right it's like she's literally got
the email she released the email gavin
newsom is saying that this is a
completely fabricated story it's like
look at rose's twitter feed the emails
are there so part two is up right now my
full interview with tucker carlson is up
as i've said a couple of times it's like
it's just tucker in a way you haven't
seen him before and and i think you'll
really enjoy it if you haven't seen it
and uh i'm almost at a million twitter
followers which makes me think that my
days on twitter are almost done like
they can't let me keep tweeting about
all the stuff i'm tweeting about and big
tech is just deeply deeply evil so if
you haven't joined us at
reubenreport.locals.com it's absolutely
free to create account and view most of
the content you just got to pay a couple
bucks if you want to you know directly
communicate with me and be part we now
do live chat also so they're right now
in the reuben report app in the locals
app at the reuben report community we
have people live chatting about the show
so you guys talking to each other it's
much better than live chat on youtube
which is the psychotic bed of scum and
villainy anyway big day
vote for larry elder if you haven't vote
twice vote three times who cares get out
there do it see ya